citation needed joining me today he
reads books you know it's Chris Joel
[Laughter]
running trailer for say Lawrence earn
depends like great please let us know if
you spot the secret shame inist message
in this show is a good in front of me
I've got an article from Wikipedia and
these folks can't see it every fact we
get right is a point and a ding and the
special prize for particular dancers
which is
oh they're in tune tonight and today we
are talking about a hail cannon is it a
cannon that shoots hail no did this
belong to Ming the Merciless cleitus I'm
bored what plaything can you offer me
today a vibrator or a cannon that shoots
are you using those for the same thing
because wow I was about to say that's a
very weird version of Flash Gordon but
there literally is mmm a parody of Flash
Gordon
that would be Flash Gordon yes which
went round at my school like hotcakes
let me tell you the hail cannon does not
shoot hail is it a meteorological event
well they say that like Michael gamble
like cloud seeding oh so a hail cannon
might be something you you set off from
a plane into the clouds to make hail
happen why would you want that
now I'm giving I'm giving biscuit for
two reasons first stereo and secondly
that is a very good question
the hail cannon does not create
hailstones
you wouldn't want that what would you
want does it stop hailstones does it
slush them it is a shockwave generator
claimed to disrupt the formation of
hailstones you look surprised by this
hailstones
well they've been shattered was this
first discovered when Brian Blessed
climbed Mount Everest in the loud enough
shock oh it's just a big bang so it is
just a cannon that makes a big loud
thing and then the big loud thing makes
the hell go no I'm not gonna be hail
anymore apparently it just looks like a
big cone with a box at the bottom of it
what are they put in the Box a man's
part then slam the lid shut oh that
would I will get a very loud noise
acetylene and oxygen is fast against the
clouds
I've talked about this before and still
yes with the u-men you have your ass
against the plane window and we're
hoping for the best
yeah but in the service of humanity it's
basically a contained poof of an
explosion and then all that force gets
projected up into the sky itsuka yeah
I'm being hesitant about saying that's
what it's doing
there's no one ever actually done it
lots of people have done it these are
installed in a lot of places has no-one
measured their success I mean they're
cited in a peer-reviewed journal Oh just
cuz it's never hailed after that's
happened doesn't mean it was gonna Hale
to begin with because you can tell there
has been a review which is why I didn't
give you a point for has no one done the
research they have done the research and
the results were inconclusive
no pretty conclusive didn't work yes
people are firing massive amounts of
explosive gases in Sierre to create a
massive boom for no reason on
yes I love our race there is another
reason to doubt it what else happens
near hailstorms that would be a heck of
a lot more powerful than one of these
cabins Ryan blessed skydiving place
Thunderbolts and lightning very very
frightening which does bring me to
something called a cloud buster
oh now this was a song by Kate Bush Oh
Jerry thank you it was this was the
device that inspired the Kate Bush song
cloud bus I'm running up that hill I'm
some things of this with an owl suppose
about there's about the man runs up a
hill uneasy
is he like a scientist who's arrested at
the nm remember in the video a modern
the actual facts here you say scientist
the man's name was Wilhelm Reich he was
Austrian and a psychoanalyst so not
innately qualified to do weather no no
and the cloudbuster wasn't like the Heil
current had a very different intent to
make it rain to make it rain by doing
what they lob dogs named buster up into
the clouds did they lob copies of the
1980s film about the Great Train Robbery
Buster into the air do you only be the
third one on this Chris okay no it was a
series of parallel hollow metal tubes at
the end
jugular bowels flexible hoses and then
those are placed in water is he shooting
water into a cloud to make it right no
I've just described the entire thing
you've got it's just a things that some
hoses and some water and it claims to
manipulate something called organ energy
Oh our gone2asia on pronunciation
no one knows and then it says it is a
pseudo scientific concept and there are
seven references after the word pseudo
scientific there's been some arguments
here officially bollocks what is orgone
energy supposed to bits it's the Chi
version but for whether it's a bit
further than that is it supposed to be
the equivalent of whatever dark matter
is is it some kind of surrounding force
that holds water in it's actually it's
not just to do with water is it a life
force there's a binding life force yes
it is essentially the force from Star
Wars it is an esoteric energy a
hypothetical universal life force and by
putting a vibraphone into some water via
some hoses I can make the force cry what
you've done there Gary is just give the
best I'd the best summing up of the
cloudbuster that I think I've ever heard
this is moving back now to actually
trying to make rain this is not organ
and the cloud buster this is the US
military and they created Operation
Popeye 1967 to 1972 any ideas where that
might have been here now yes absolutely
right why might the US military during
the Vietnam War have wanted to make ray
is this no pump no no this is literal
rain is it is it to kind of drive them
out of the jungle because it's so very
wet and horrible and they don't like it
you know is it to wash off all the Agent
Orange that they've used to poison the
entire country oh is it to get Agent
Orange into the rainfall and then use
that to drop it rather than play no it's
actually it's more of a tactic about
logistics it's mainly matte roads muddy
yes new things around yes
soften the road surfaces caused
landslides wash out river crossings on
one other thing about the climate in
Vietnam make it very humid and they're
always already is what happens there
about certain times of year monsoon is
yes the idea was to extend monsoon
season with the 54th weather
reconnaissance
squadron who had a slogan and it was it
ended with the words not war
what were the first to make a train make
something not war water ok
you got the ground you put them together
slippery yes sounds perfectly reasonable
to me make mud when they making mud to
make 450 experiments in the the Laos
Panhandle and the government of Laos
what do they think about this
did they not even notice because nothing
happened yeah you're close but no well
they annoyed that they were flying about
all that and then nothing happened no no
they weren't annoyed by it at all did
they like it cause it was it their crops
with them no they didn't like it either
did they notice they weren't actually
even told about it cheeki the US
government just decides to fly over and
seed some clouds with lead iodide and
silver I adore or that bad they are
apple rain yes I've never listened to
the lyrics of Purple Rain before these
are vitamin e figure are they about this
no no no wait I'm gonna check that
because let me let me tell you if it
turns out Purple Rain is actually about
the US military's cloud-seeding
experiments in Laos I am giving you
biscuits Prince explained the meaning of
Purple Rain as follows when there's
blood in the sky red and blue equals
purple so unfortunately no it's not
about the US military seating with
letterhead of height but it could have
been yeah let iodide is not actually
purple oh no as soon as you change ID
and it's something else that loses
colour in fact kill humor kids but the
question is did it work no no yes
correct because everything
82% of the clouds produced rain within a
brief period after having been seeded
Wow so very wet so it did work but
nowadays you're not allowed to do that
why not some kind of treaty that says
don't do that what if what weather
modification treaties cause it could be
used as an act of war oh you are
absolutely right it is the environmental
modification convention have a point
which was signed whether a booger about
you treaty yes the weather a buggery
bible tea treaty sounds really hard to
say the weather it bothering about sea
treaty weather a bogey about tea treaty
and now we're going to a song yes it is
a ban on weather modification techniques
and on the use of herbicides in warfare
when might that have come into use and
Vietnam yeah in 1977 Agent Orange and
everything was banned by that treaty did
they bomb the modification of Kate Bush
as well how would you modify Kate Bush
you're right she can't be improved to
puff there is a link at the bottom of
Operation Popeye does it say never get
involved in a land war in Asia it says
it says project Stormfury I want a badge
I want a hat with it on the whole thing
project Stormfury unless he killed a lot
of people in which case I am less
interested what was the US government
trying to do between 62 and 83 with
planes filled with silver iodide as the
weather on anger the weather yes
make friends with weather and then use
it against the why would the US
government not the military I know he
said u.s. mail people is a government
why would they want to modify the
weather on a large scale get rid of the
tornado about oh it's it's close it's
not quite tornadoes but something else
that's been hitting them more lately Oh
okand yes tropical cyclones the idea was
that they would fly an aircraft into a
cyclone was it hurricane um
fire hurricane into a hurricane is a
type of plate used in the olden days no
it was a lockheed p-3 is that a dull
plane that was a dull fact or it's a
dull plate it's a dull in being flown
into a hurricane what you think it's
just a way to get rid of them we need
more b-1 bombers they go swing wings god
dammit find peace regional hurricane
turn that recording of the meeting off
we've heard enough yeah the idea was
that it would just fly in just fly in to
a lot presumably with slim pickins on
the tough finish cowboy huh and the
answer is they probably didn't make it
work but we still have lots of
hurricanes yeah it probably wasn't
actually going to affect anything but
they did get a positive outcome out of
it what might that have been the family
didn't work but that involves doing
something finding that out a massive
amount of weather research yes that's
absolutely right out of this attempt to
seed the clouds they found a huge amount
of research that helped them forecast a
future hurricanes and say this sounds
very 50s but the fact that are actually
trying it feels a bit later 1962 to 1983
have the last point yeah
and with that congratulations Matt you
win the show yeah you in a vertical
purple LED ass it's a plum plum plum bum
bum with that we say thank you to Chris
y'all to Gary Brannen to Matt gray ugly
Tom Scott we'll see you next time
you